This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.|||这是一个 I-Heart 播客。绝对真人。嘿，大家最近怎么样？欢迎收听《Learn the Hardway》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖恩斯（Kear Gaines）。这个节目探讨的是黑人男性的经历，进行那些在别处根本不敢进行的坦诚对话，而你是在与一位懂行的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着一套铠甲。这向世界发出信号：你可不是好惹的。这并不意味着你有这个能力，就必须去使用它，听听学学吧。
the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier,
the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier,|||在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或其他你获取播客的平台搜索《Learn the Hardway》。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在这个奇怪的现代世界中如何建立心理韧性、保持健康以及培养适应力。经历一些艰难困苦，你将在另一端成为一个更快乐、
more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.|||更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或任何你收听播客的地方搜索 TWO%。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个声名狼藉的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，要相信你的闺蜜。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 is big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 is big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.|||请收听《Trust me, babe》。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或任何你收听播客的地方订阅。欢迎收听《Look Back at it》播客。从 1979 年开始，那对我和我来说是个重要的时刻。84年对我也意义重大。我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利什（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。
With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is great to have you here.
With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is great to have you here.|||和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）谈论 80 年代。84年真是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或任何你收听播客的地方收听《Look Back at it》。大家好，欢迎回到《20多岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们探讨 20 多岁时经历的一些重大生活变化和转变，以及它们对我们心理的意义。大家好。欢迎回到本节目。欢迎回到本播客。很高兴你能来。
new listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. Hi, my chronic overthinkers, all of my fellow anxious friends out there. Welcome to this week's episode. Today, we are discussing the psychology of overthinking and chronic indecisiveness. This has been raised by you guys again and again as a huge challenge and experience in your 20s. And personally, I can really relate. I don't know why I have not done this topic before, especially considering my own personal experience. Overthinking is such a maze that really feels impossible to get out of. Our thoughts can be so loud and so difficult to navigate.
new listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. Hi, my chronic overthinkers, all of my fellow anxious friends out there. Welcome to this week's episode. Today, we are discussing the psychology of overthinking and chronic indecisiveness. This has been raised by you guys again and again as a huge challenge and experience in your 20s. And personally, I can really relate. I don't know why I have not done this topic before, especially considering my own personal experience. Overthinking is such a maze that really feels impossible to get out of. Our thoughts can be so loud and so difficult to navigate.|||新听众、老听众，无论你身在世界的哪个角落。嗨，我的重度想太多患者们，所有身处焦虑之中的朋友们。欢迎收听本周的节目。今天，我们要讨论的是过度思考和慢性优柔寡断的心理学。你们一次又一次地提到，这是你们在 20 多岁时面临的巨大挑战和体验。就我个人而言，我真的感同身受。我不知道为什么我以前没有做过这个主题，尤其是考虑到我自己的个人经历。想太多就像一个迷宫，真的让人感觉无法自拔。我们的思绪可以如此喧嚣，如此难以掌控。
And they can result in this spiral where we feel like we've been thinking about one small thing for hours and hours, or we are absolutely paralyzed by indecision because what if we haven't considered all possible outcomes? there is a psychological reason a lot of us find ourselves feeling this way and adopting, I would say, a maladaptive thinking style. And with most things, I think an explanation can be incredibly liberating. I personally find it so infuriating when people talk about living in the moment or instruct you to just simply stop thinking about it. It really overlooks so many of the deeper cognitive roots of this experience ranging from,
And they can result in this spiral where we feel like we've been thinking about one small thing for hours and hours, or we are absolutely paralyzed by indecision because what if we haven't considered all possible outcomes? there is a psychological reason a lot of us find ourselves feeling this way and adopting, I would say, a maladaptive thinking style. And with most things, I think an explanation can be incredibly liberating. I personally find it so infuriating when people talk about living in the moment or instruct you to just simply stop thinking about it. It really overlooks so many of the deeper cognitive roots of this experience ranging from,|||它们可能会导致这样一种恶性循环：我们觉得自己为了某件小事想了好几个小时，或者我们因为优柔寡断而彻底瘫痪，因为“万一我们没有考虑到所有可能的结果呢？”。我们很多人发现自己会有这种感觉，并采用了一种可以说是适应不良的思维方式，这背后是有心理学原因的。对于大多数事情，我认为一个解释可以带来巨大的解脱。我个人觉得，当人们谈论活在当下或者指导你“别再去想了”时，真的非常令人恼火。这完全忽视了这种体验背后的许多更深层的认知根源，包括：
a fear of uncertainty to perfectionism, trauma, childhood learning, and even comorbid mental health conditions like anxiety and ADHD. It's not all within your control. There are so many hidden elements of overthinking that we do not discuss. And then, of course, there's the indecision. We've spoken about the paradox of choice on the podcast before, but essentially it's this theory that when we have a lot of options, it actually becomes harder to make a decision compared to when we have fewer options,
a fear of uncertainty to perfectionism, trauma, childhood learning, and even comorbid mental health conditions like anxiety and ADHD. It's not all within your control. There are so many hidden elements of overthinking that we do not discuss. And then, of course, there's the indecision. We've spoken about the paradox of choice on the podcast before, but essentially it's this theory that when we have a lot of options, it actually becomes harder to make a decision compared to when we have fewer options,|||从对不确定性的恐惧到完美主义、创伤、童年的学习经历，甚至是焦虑和 ADHD 等共病的心理健康状况。这一切并非全在你的掌控之中。过度思考中有太多我们没有讨论过的隐藏因素。当然，还有优柔寡断。我们以前在播客中讨论过“选择的悖论”，但本质上这就是这样一个理论：当我们在有很多选项时，相比于选项较少时，其实更难做出决定，
because we become paralyzed almost by the possibilities. That's particularly pertinent, I would say, for those of us in our 20s, because we are just at the beginning of a long journey and range of life decisions. And during this period, I think we are typically presented with a lot of different options and paths. You know, what do I study at university? what if I want to go and travel for a few years, which of these job offers do I say yes to? Do I move to this new city or do I settle down? You know, we don't want to box ourselves in, but what I'm personally seeing more of anecdotally
because we become paralyzed almost by the possibilities. That's particularly pertinent, I would say, for those of us in our 20s, because we are just at the beginning of a long journey and range of life decisions. And during this period, I think we are typically presented with a lot of different options and paths. You know, what do I study at university? what if I want to go and travel for a few years, which of these job offers do I say yes to? Do I move to this new city or do I settle down? You know, we don't want to box ourselves in, but what I'm personally seeing more of anecdotally|||因为我们几乎被各种可能性弄得瘫痪了。我想，这对于我们这些二十多岁的人来说尤其贴切，因为我们正处于漫长旅程和一系列生活抉择的起点。在这个时期，我认为我们通常会面临许多不同的选择和道路。你知道的，大学里我该学什么专业？如果我想去旅行几年会怎么样？这些工作机会我该接受哪一个？我是搬到一个新城市还是安定下来？你知道的，我们不想把自己局限住，但我个人从轶事中看到更多的是：
is a generation, you know, my generation, our generation, of people that are so overwhelmed by options that they actually remain quite stagnant because of that fear around making the wrong choice. And I think a lot of that can be explained by our tendency to overthink. And if that sounds like you, you are most certainly not alone. I think although the experience of overthinking can feel incredibly isolating, it is a hugely common experience. And the good news is that you kind of have the power to reprogram your brain. You can unlearn these patterns of thinking. And that's really when I want to talk about today, we're going to break down the mysteries of overthinking from the origins and the reasons why we overthink, why it may actually indicate a greater level of
is a generation, you know, my generation, our generation, of people that are so overwhelmed by options that they actually remain quite stagnant because of that fear around making the wrong choice. And I think a lot of that can be explained by our tendency to overthink. And if that sounds like you, you are most certainly not alone. I think although the experience of overthinking can feel incredibly isolating, it is a hugely common experience. And the good news is that you kind of have the power to reprogram your brain. You can unlearn these patterns of thinking. And that's really when I want to talk about today, we're going to break down the mysteries of overthinking from the origins and the reasons why we overthink, why it may actually indicate a greater level of|||这样一代人（你知道的，我这一代人，我们这一代人）：他们被各种选择压得喘不过气来，以至于因为害怕做出错误的选择而停滞不前。我认为这很大程度上可以用我们倾向于过度思考来解释。如果这听起来像是在说你，你绝对不是一个人。我认为，尽管过度思考的体验可能会让人感到无比孤独，但它是一种非常普遍的经历。好消息是，你拥有重新编程大脑的力量。你可以改掉这些思维模式。这正是今天我想谈的内容，我们将从过度思考的起源和原因、为什么它实际上可能表明更高水平的
self-awareness, how it links to diagnosable mental health conditions, and some of the leading theories and tips on how we can stop overthinking, not through rationality, but through a bit of delusion and distraction. I'm personally very much in need of this episode. I don't know about you. And also, before we get into it, special thank you to Nish, a wonderful listener from Sydney, who came up to me whilst I was eating sushi at the food court. Very glamorous.
self-awareness, how it links to diagnosable mental health conditions, and some of the leading theories and tips on how we can stop overthinking, not through rationality, but through a bit of delusion and distraction. I'm personally very much in need of this episode. I don't know about you. And also, before we get into it, special thank you to Nish, a wonderful listener from Sydney, who came up to me whilst I was eating sushi at the food court. Very glamorous.|||自我意识、它如何与可诊断的心理健康状况联系起来，以及关于如何停止过度思考的一些主要理论和技巧（不是通过理性，而是通过一点幻想和转移注意力）来剖析过度思考的奥秘。我个人非常需要这一集。不知道你们呢。另外，在进入正题之前，特别感谢尼什（Nish），一位来自悉尼的超级棒的听众，当我在美食广场吃寿司时，她走过来找我。非常高大上。
But she actually helped pick this week's episode. So we all have heard of thank for this topic. I think without further ado, let's get into the nitty-gritty around the psychology of overthinking. and indecisiveness. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
But she actually helped pick this week's episode. So we all have heard of thank for this topic. I think without further ado, let's get into the nitty-gritty around the psychology of overthinking. and indecisiveness. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.|||但她实际上帮助挑选了本周的节目主题。所以我们都得感谢她提出这个话题。我想废话不多说，让我们深入探讨过度思考和优柔寡断的心理学的核心细节吧。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts,
I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts,|||我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在这个奇怪的现代世界中如何建立心理韧性、保持健康以及培养适应力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家对话，
and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress.
and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress.|||等等，带大家看透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾经坚信种子油天生具有炎症性。我们弄错了。世界上让我们感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people.
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people.|||经历一些艰难困苦，你将在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、 healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在 VMA 上双击小金（Little Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不喜欢黑人时。
I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack.
I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack.|||我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一集有马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）做客，大谈 80 年代的快克（crack）。需要说明的是，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。
I'm down to talk about crack on day But just so y'all know I mean at this point Mark this is the second episode where we've discussed crack So I'm starting to see that there's a through line We also have AIDS on the table right now So
I'm down to talk about crack on day But just so y'all know I mean at this point Mark this is the second episode where we've discussed crack So I'm starting to see that there's a through line We also have AIDS on the table right now So|||我随时准备好聊聊快克。但我要让大家知道，马克，这是我们第二次讨论快克了。所以我开始发现这其中有一条主线。我们现在还把“艾滋病”摆在了台面上。所以
Thank you finishing that sentence I don't think there's a more important year For black people Really? Yeah for me it's one of the most important years For black people in American history Listen to look back at it On the IHeart Radio app
Thank you finishing that sentence I don't there's a more important year For black people Really? Yeah for me it's one of the most important years For black people in American history Listen to look back at it On the IHeart Radio app|||谢谢你帮我把那句话说完。我认为没有比这更重要的年份了。对于黑人来说。真的吗？是的，对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。请在 iHeartRadio App 上收听《Look Back at it》
Apple Podcasts Or wherever you get your podcasts Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't
Apple Podcasts Or wherever you get your podcasts Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't|||Apple Podcasts 或任何你收听播客的地方。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》，我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师凯尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）。为了响应心理健康意识月，我带来了自己十多年在心理健康领域的经验，并与许多出色的嘉宾进行了对话。我说的是特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太专注于追逐，以至于我们没有
realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth, or are you a good person because you're afraid?
realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth, or are you a good person because you're afraid?|||意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐。我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们总是盯着记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得在这个世上做一个好人很重要，还是你做一个好人只是因为你害怕？
Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way.
Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way.|||因为兄弟，那是两种不同的意图。完全正确。这也是两个不同层级的信任。我希望你能真正做一个好人。和我凯尔·盖恩斯（Kear Gaines）一起，在我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》中，就疗愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和人生目标展开真实的对话。
Open your free, our heart radio app, Search learning a hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case.
Open your free, our heart radio app, Search learning a hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case.|||打开你免费的 iHeartRadio App，搜索《Learn the Hardway》并立即收听。2023 年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克哈德（Clayton Eckerd）发现自己卷入了一起亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭露了他故事中明显的矛盾之处。这引发了一场长达数年的法庭之战以证明真相。你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这花费了一大批互联网侦探才破获了此案。
I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, the lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap.
I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, the lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap.|||我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税都被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。又有两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格（Greg）、女同性恋者、迈克尔·马拉蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《Love Trap》。
Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until Justice. is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until Justice. is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.|||劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻：劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或任何你收听播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。
As always, let's start with the basics. What actually is overthinking? Obviously, we are constantly thinking at all times. So it's not the quantity of thoughts. That's the problem here, but actually the opposite. It's when our thoughts lack nuance, because we become fixated and stuck on one thing in particular, maybe that is a certain situation or a topic or a person or a hypothetical that we cannot stop returning to in which we analyze for excessive periods of time. These kind of thoughts
As always, let's start with the basics. What actually is overthinking? Obviously, we are constantly thinking at all times. So it's not the quantity of thoughts. That's the problem here, but actually the opposite. It's when our thoughts lack nuance, because we become fixated and stuck on one thing in particular, maybe that is a certain situation or a topic or a person or a hypothetical that we cannot stop returning to in which we analyze for excessive periods of time. These kind of thoughts|||一如既往，让我们从基础开始。到底什么是过度思考？很明显，我们无时无刻不在思考。所以问题不在于思考的数量。问题不在这儿，实际上恰恰相反。当我们的思绪缺乏细微差别时，是因为我们对某一件特定的事情变得固执和执着，也许那是某种特定情况、某个话题、某个人或某种我们无法停止回想并进行过度分析的假设。这类想法
are what we would call maladaptive, meaning not appropriate because we can become obsessive and these cognitions begin to control us rather than the other way around. If you feel like you can't relax, that your brain will not shut off even when you want it to, that's a massive indicator that you are someone who is an overthinker. This pattern, it actually normally suggests that there is something beyond your control that is bothering you. And by mulling it over and over again and examining it from every direction, we give ourselves a sense of agency over whatever we're thinking about. Often, though, you know, when this type of thinking becomes habitual,
are what we would call maladaptive, meaning not appropriate because we can become obsessive and these cognitions begin to control us rather than the other way around. If you feel like you can't relax, that your brain will not shut off even when you want it to, that's a massive indicator that you are someone who is an overthinker. This pattern, it actually normally suggests that there is something beyond your control that is bothering you. And by mulling it over and over again and examining it from every direction, we give ourselves a sense of agency over whatever we're thinking about. Often, though, you know, when this type of thinking becomes habitual,|||就是我们所谓的适应不良，意思是说它是不恰当的，因为我们会变得强迫性，这些认知开始控制我们，而不是我们控制它们。如果你觉得你无法放松，即使你想让大脑停下来它也停不下来，这是一个强烈的信号，表明你是一个过度思考者。这种模式实际上通常表明有什么超出你控制的事情在困扰着你。通过一遍又一遍地琢磨它，从各个方向审视它，我们让自己对所思考的事情产生了一种掌控感。然而通常情况下，你知道的，当这种思考方式变成习惯时，
we are met with chronic indecisiveness. A key hallmark of overthinking is the inability to resolve a specific thought. And so when we cannot move past our doubts or we cannot stop questioning our next move or ruminating on something that's happened, we naturally can't make progress. And I think this results in a stalemate. You know, you are going to struggle to move forward or make a decision if you're not actually clear on how you think about the situation or you're still stuck in that thought spiral. I'll give you this example that I was thinking about, and that is thinking about your ex-partner,
we are met with chronic indecisiveness. A key hallmark of overthinking is the inability to resolve a specific thought. And so when we cannot move past our doubts or we cannot stop questioning our next move or ruminating on something that's happened, we naturally can't make progress. And I think this results in the stalemate. You know, you are going to struggle to move forward or make a decision if you're not actually clear on how you think about the situation or you're still stuck in that thought spiral. I'll give you this example that I was thinking about, and that is thinking about your ex-partner,|||我们会遇到长期的优柔寡断。过度思考的一个关键标志是无法解决一个具体的想法。因此，当我们无法跨越疑虑，或者无法停止质疑我们的下一步行动，或者无法停止对已经发生的事情进行反刍时，我们自然无法取得进展。我认为这会导致僵局。你知道的，如果你实际上不清楚自己对这种情况的看法，或者你仍然陷入那种思维的漩涡中，你将很难向前迈进或做出决定。我举一个我一直在想的例子，那就是想起你的前任伴侣，
thinking about someone that you loved, and everything that went wrong and all the what-ifs and you're ruminating about past events and you're kind of somewhat frozen in those memories. You can't make a decision about how you want to heal or move forward. you can't begin to date new people or reclaim your own mental space and thoughts if you cannot break out of this loop. I think another source of overthinking, particularly during our 20s, is this age-old conundrum of, would my life turn out better if I were to do things differently or make a certain set of decisions? Like I spoke about earlier, we're really faced with an endless list of possibilities or options during this decade, but also a lack of hindsight to
thinking about someone that you loved, and everything that wrong and all the what-ifs and you're ruminating about past events and you're kind of somewhat frozen in those memories. You can't make a decision about how you want to heal or move forward. you can't begin to date new people or reclaim your own mental space and thoughts if you cannot break out of this loop. I think another source of overthinking, particularly during our 20s, is this age-old conundrum of, would my life turn out better if I were to do things differently or make a certain set of decisions? Like I spoke about earlier, we're really faced with an endless list of possibilities or options during this decade, but also a lack of hindsight to|||想起你曾经爱过的人，以及所有出错的事情和所有的“如果……会怎样”，你在对过去的事件进行反刍，某种程度上你被冻结在那些记忆中了。你无法就如何疗愈或继续前进做出决定。如果你无法打破这个循环，你就无法开始与新人约会，也无法收回属于你自己的心理空间和思绪。我认为过度思考的另一个来源，特别是在我们的 20 多岁期间，是这个古老的难题：如果我采取不同的做法或做出一系列特定的决定，我的生活会不会更好？正如我前面所说，在这十年里，我们确实面临着无穷无尽的可能性或选择，但也缺乏事后诸葛亮般的视角来
make sense of what we actually want. And I think overthinking tricks us into thinking that what we're doing is somehow helpful and that if we constantly mull over and think about what we want or this situation, we'll somehow find some hidden solution that we hadn't actually found before. And that's not always the case. I think we often find ourselves in a sense. state of what we call analysis paralysis, whereby the more we think about something, the harder it actually becomes to make a decision because we have too much information to process and too many variables to consider. And as we know, contrary to popular belief, humans are actually better at making decisions when they have less information or choices to consider. There's this other side
make sense of what we actually want. And I think overthinking tricks us into thinking that what we're doing is somehow helpful and that if we constantly mull over and think about what we want or this situation, we'll somehow find some hidden solution that we hadn't actually found before. And that's not always the case. I think we often find ourselves in a sense. state of what we call analysis paralysis, whereby the more we think about something, the harder it actually becomes to make a decision because we have too much information to process and too many variables to consider. And as we know, contrary to popular belief, humans are actually better at making decisions when they have less information or choices to consider. There's this other side|||弄明白我们到底想要什么。并且我认为，过度思考欺骗了我们，让我们以为我们正在做的事情在某种程度上是有帮助的，如果我们不断琢磨和思考我们想要什么或这种情况，我们就会以某种方式找到以前没有发现的隐藏解决方案。事实并非总是如此。我认为我们经常会陷入一种我们称之为“分析瘫痪”的状态，即我们对某件事思考得越多，实际上就越难做出决定，因为我们需要处理的信息太多，需要考虑的变量也太多。正如我们所知，与普遍看法相反，当人类需要考虑的信息或选择较少时，实际上更擅长做出决定。还有另一面
to overthinking as well, which is worrying about how others perceive us. If you find yourself in your head a lot like myself or, you know, when you're around people, you really can't break away from thinking about how they're perceiving you, it can really take away from those interactions and the quality of those relationships. I think the approval of others is something that we all innately crave. But studies have shown that we consistently overestimate how much they're actually thinking about us. I said this to my friend the other day, but no one is thinking about you as deeply as you're thinking about yourself. We are very much self-centered, self-absorbed creatures. And yet,
to overthinking as well, which is worrying about how others perceive us. If you find yourself in your head a lot like myself, or, you know, when you're around people, you really can't break away from thinking about how they're perceiving you, it can really take away from those interactions and the quality of those relationships. I think the approval of others is something that we all innately crave. But studies have shown that we consistently overestimate how much they're actually thinking about us. I said this to my friend the other day, but no one is thinking about you as deeply as you're thinking about yourself. We are very much self-centered, self-absorbed creatures. And yet,|||关于过度思考，那就是担心别人如何看待我们。如果你发现自己经常陷在自己的脑海里（就像我一样），或者，你知道的，当你和别人在一起时，你真的无法摆脱去想他们是如何看待你的，这真的会削弱这些互动和这些关系的质量。我认为获得他人的认可是我们所有人内心里都渴望的。但研究表明，我们总是高估了他们实际对我们的关注程度。我前几天对我的朋友说过这话：没有人像你自己那样深刻地思考着你。我们是非常以自我为中心、自我陶醉的生物。然而，
I think we've all had those moments where we've changed a million times before a social event because we are overthinking what others will think of us. Or you've ruminated for hours on some tiny, tiny part of an otherwise pleasant interaction with someone. because you're so concerned with how you came off. There's actually a name for this in psychology. It's called allodoxophobia, and it's essentially intense anxiety about the approval of others. And I would say it's highly correlated with overthinking.
I think we've all had those moments where we've changed a million times before a social event because we are overthinking what others will think of us. Or you've ruminated for hours on some tiny, tiny part of an otherwise pleasant interaction with someone. because you're so concerned with how you came off. There's actually a name for this in psychology. It's called allodoxophobia, and it's essentially intense anxiety about the approval of others. And I would say it's highly correlated with overthinking.|||我想我们都有过这样的时刻：在参加社交活动前换了一百万次衣服，因为我们过度思考别人会对我们有什么看法。或者你为了一次原本很愉快的互动中的某个极其微小的部分而反思了好几个小时，因为你太在意自己给别人留下了什么印象。在心理学中，这其实有一个专门的名字。它被称为“异见恐惧症”（allodoxophobia），本质上是对他人认可的强烈焦虑。我想说，它与过度思考高度相关。
The good news is, well, not really good news, but an element of this that I think might make us feel better, is that if you are an overthinker, as much as it can be incredibly mentally exhausted, and paralyzing, it may actually indicate that you're probably more self-aware and emotionally intelligent compared to the average person. Self-awareness, by definition, refers to the ability to observe your own thoughts and recognize how you are perceived by others, but also internally being able to identify what makes you an individual and the impact of your decisions. This is
The good news is, well, not really good news, but an element of this that I think might make us feel better, is that if you are an overthinker, as much as it can be incredibly mentally exhausted, and paralyzing, it may actually indicate that you're probably more self-aware and emotionally intelligent compared to the average person. Self-awareness, by definition, refers to the ability to observe your own thoughts and recognize how you are perceived by others, but also internally being able to identify what makes you an individual and the impact of your decisions. This is|||好消息是（好吧，其实算不上什么好消息，但其中有一点可能会让我们感觉好受一些）：如果你是一个过度思考者，尽管它可能会在精神上让人精疲力竭且陷入瘫痪，但这实际上可能表明，与普通人相比，你可能具有更高的自我意识和情商。按定义来说，自我意识是指观察自己想法的能力，并认识到自己是如何被他人所看待的，同时在内心里能够识别是什么让你成为一个独立的个体以及你所做决定的影响。这
unsurprisingly linked to our emotional intelligence. And what that refers to is the ability to recognize the influence of your emotions and actions on others. Thinking about an issue from different perspectives and reflecting on how a decision may affect others, especially your loved ones, it really allows for greater empathy. You know, you look internally and you're able to see correlations between how you act and how others respond. So if you're someone who typically sits with your thoughts for, I would say, an uncomfortable period of time. The chances are that you, as a consequence, are much more ensued with how your decisions not only influence the people around you, hence that level of or need for social approval, but also your own internal
unsurprisingly linked to our emotional intelligence. And what that refers to is the ability to recognize the influence of your emotions and actions on others. Thinking about an issue from different perspectives and reflecting on how a decision may affect others, especially your loved ones, it really allows for greater empathy. You know, you look internally and you're able to see correlations between how you act and how others respond. So if you're someone who typically sits with your thoughts for, I would say, an uncomfortable period of time. The chances are that you, as a consequence, are much more ensued with how your decisions not only influence the people around you, hence that level of or need for social approval, but also your own internal|||毫无意外地与我们的情商挂钩。情商指的是识别你的情绪和行为对他人影响的能力。从不同的角度思考问题，并反思一个决定可能会如何影响他人（尤其是你爱的人），这确实能带来更强的同理心。你知道的，你向内审视，并且能够看出你的行为与他人的反应之间的关联。所以，如果你是一个通常会与自己的思绪共处一段（依我看来）令人不适的时间的人，那么结果很可能是，你更加关注你的决定不仅如何影响你周围的人（因此产生了那种对社会认可的程度或需求），而且如何影响你自己的内心
self-perception and your future. That, I think, is a beautiful quality, but it also comes with its burdens. A question I actually get a lot is, can I be too self-aware? And I think when we examine the relationship to overthinking, the answer is yes. When we fall into the trap of over-analyzing everything, a few things occur. Firstly, of course, that chronic indecisiveness, but also an inability to focus on our responsibilities, perhaps a failure to see the bigger picture, and that results in anxiety and at times panic, but also from the outside it can look like self-absorption. I don't necessarily think that's the case because a lot of the time when we overthink, we're mostly worried about others or the feelings of others, but when you do spend too much
self-perception and your future. That, I think, is a beautiful quality, but it also comes with its burdens. A question I actually get a lot is, can I be too self-aware? And I think when we examine the relationship to overthinking, the answer is yes. When we fall into the trap of over-analyzing everything, a few things occur. Firstly, of course, that chronic indecisiveness, but also an inability to focus on our responsibilities, perhaps a failure to see the bigger picture, and that results in anxiety and at times panic, but also from the outside it can look like self-absorption. I don't necessarily think that's the case because a lot of the time when we overthink, we're mostly worried about others or the feelings of others, but when you do spend too much|||自我认知和你的未来。我认为，这是一种美好的品质，但它也伴随着它的重担。我经常遇到的一个问题是：我会不会过于有自我意识了？我想，当我们审视它与过度思考的关系时，答案是肯定的。当我们陷入对一切事物过度分析的陷阱时，会发生几件事。首先，当然是那种长期的优柔寡断，但也伴随着无法专注于我们的责任，也许是无法看清大局，这会导致焦虑，有时甚至是恐慌，但从外表来看，它也可能看起来像是自我陶醉。我并不一定认为情况就是这样，因为很多时候当我们过度思考时，我们大多是在为别人或别人的感受担忧，但当你确实花费了太多
time inside your own thoughts, sometimes it can be hard to get that perspective you need to make the right decision or to really see clearly what the situation is. So why does this occur. That's a million dollar question, isn't it? Well, psychology gives us a few answers, and the primary ones are this fear of uncertainty and an illusion of control, a fear of failure, and I think that's really linked to perfectionism and procrastination, and then also our childhood environment and the chaos that may have been our childhood and things like generalized anxiety disorder, depression, and ADHD. This fear of uncertainty, I think is perhaps one of the best explanations in my opinion for why we overthink. Humans do not deal well with
time inside your own thoughts, sometimes it can be hard to get that perspective you need to make the right decision or to really see clearly what the situation is. So why does this occur. That's a million dollar question, isn't. Well, psychology gives us a few answers, and the primary ones are this fear of uncertainty and an illusion of control, a fear of failure, and I think that's really linked to perfectionism and procrastination, and then also our childhood environment and the chaos that may have been our childhood and things like generalized anxiety disorder, depression, and ADHD. This fear of uncertainty, I think is perhaps one of the best explanations in my opinion for why we overthink. Humans do not deal well with|||时间沉浸在自己的思绪中时，有时很难获得做出正确决定所需的视角，或者很难真正看清情况到底是什么。那么，为什么会出现这种情况呢？这是一个价值百万的问题，不是吗？好吧，心理学给我们提供了一些答案，其中最主要的有：对不确定性的恐惧和虚幻的控制感，对失败的恐惧（我认为这真的与完美主义和拖延症有关），还有我们的童年环境以及我们童年时期可能经历的混乱，以及广泛性焦虑症、抑郁症和多动症（ADHD）之类的问题。依我之见，这种对不确定性的恐惧，可能是在我们为什么会过度思考这一问题上最好的解释之一。人类不善于应对
unknowns because unknowns present danger or risk that could potentially indicate situations that may jeopardize our survival. It makes us really uncomfortable to not know the outcome. And they've actually proved this in a series of studies looking at the impact of uncertainty on our brain and our body. In these experiments, I think they were conducted in like the late 90s, but I'll have to fact check myself there. In these experiments, they hooked participants up to a series of electrodes that could deliver like a slight electric shock.
unknowns because unknowns present danger or risk that could potentially indicate situations that may jeopardize our survival. It makes us really uncomfortable to not know the outcome. And they've actually proved this in a series of studies looking at the impact of uncertainty on our brain and our body. In these experiments, I think they were conducted in like the late 90s, but I'll have to fact check myself there. In these experiments, they hooked participants up to a series of electrodes that could deliver like a slight electric shock.|||未知事物，因为未知事物代表着危险或风险，这些危险或风险可能预示着会危及我们生存的情况。不知道结果会让我们感到非常不安。在一系列研究不确定性对我们大脑和身体影响的研究中，他们实际上已经证明了这一点。在这些实验中（我想它们大概是在 90 年代末进行的，不过我得核实一下），在这些实验中，他们将参与者连接到一系列能够产生轻微电击的电极上。
It wasn't too painful, but it was definitely there. They then either told participants when they would shock them, they gave them almost like a timeline, or they left it ambiguous. So the shock could come at any time and the participant wouldn't know. So the participants who experienced the unpredictability condition, so the second condition, they reported significantly more discomfort, more anxiety and more pain despite the level of the shock being the same compared to those who knew when the shock was going to occur. And this basically demonstrated that uncertainty, unknowns, they can really intensify how threatening
It wasn't too painful, but it was definitely there. They then either told participants when they would shock them, they gave them almost like a timeline, or they left it ambiguous. So the shock could come at any time and the participant wouldn't know. So the participants who experienced the unpredictability condition, so the second condition, they reported significantly more discomfort, more anxiety and more pain despite the level of the shock being the same compared to those who knew when the shock was going to occur. And this basically demonstrated that uncertainty, unknowns, they can really intensify how threatening|||不是很痛，但确实有感觉。然后，他们要么告诉参与者什么时候会电击他们（几乎给他们提供了一个时间表），要么对时间保密。因此，电击可能在任何时候到来，参与者无从得知。因此，经历不可预测条件（即第二种条件）的参与者报告了明显更多的不适、更多的焦虑和更多的痛苦，尽管电击的水平是相同的，相比于那些知道电击何时会发生的人。这基本上表明，不确定性、未知事物，它们确实会加剧威胁感：
a situation feels and can also result in the state of hypervigilance where we cannot break out of just thinking about this one stimulus. When is the shock going to happen? What do I do to prepare for it? You know, those people who knew that the shock was going to occur, they had the timeline, they had the roster, they were able to let their mind wander, whereas the other set of participants were so consumed with thoughts and anxiety. In other words, they really began to over think their circumstances and what they were about to receive, what they could expect. I think our reaction to uncertainty has an evolutionary process. Our brain wants to ensure our survival and it wants to predict what is going to happen next
a situation feels and can also result in the state of hypervigilance where we cannot break out of just thinking about this one stimulus. When is the shock going to happen? What do I do to prepare for it? You know, those people who knew that the shock was going to occur, they had the timeline, they had the roster, they were able to let their mind wander, whereas the other set of participants were so consumed with thoughts and anxiety. In other words, they really began to over think their circumstances and what they were about to receive, what they could expect. I think our reaction to uncertainty has an evolutionary process. Our brain wants to ensure our survival and it wants to predict what is going to happen next|||情况感觉如何，并且还会导致高度警惕的状态，在这种状态下，我们无法摆脱仅仅去思考这一个刺激。电击什么时候会发生？我该做些什么来准备？你知道的，那些知道电击将会发生的人，他们有时间表，他们有名单，他们能够让自己的思绪走神，而另一组参与者则被各种想法和焦虑吞噬了。换句话说，他们真的开始过度思考他们的处境以及他们即将接受的、他们可以预期的东西。我认为我们对不确定性的反应是一个进化过程。我们的大脑想要确保我们的生存，它想要预测接下来会发生什么，
because it allows us to prepare our body and our mind in the most effective way possible. So in uncertain situations, that planning is a lot harder. And so our brain uses overthinking as a way to. bring a sense of calm and control to the chaos. When we face ambiguous situations, our brain wants to find the most possible outcome. And so what it does is it sends our brain spiraling. It sends us thinking about every single possible catastrophe. When we think about that in the sense of our 20s, right, there are a lot of unknowns. We are, depending on where you're out in your 20s still quite young. You know, some of us have only really been adults for like two years
because it allows us to prepare our body and our mind in the most effective way possible. So in uncertain situations, that planning is a lot harder. And so our brain uses overthinking as a way to. bring a sense of calm and control to the chaos. When we face ambiguous situations, our brain wants to find the most possible outcome. And so what it does is it sends our brain spiraling. It sends us thinking about every single possible catastrophe. When we think about that in the sense of our 20s, right, there are a lot of unknowns. We are, depending on where you're out in your 20s still quite young. You know, some of us have only really been adults for like two years|||因为它让我们能够以尽可能最有效的方式为我们的身体和思维做好准备。所以在不确定情况下，这种规划要困难得多。因此，我们的大脑利用过度思考来为混乱带来平静感和控制感。当我们面对模棱两可的情况时，我们的大脑想要找出最可能的结果。所以它所做的是让我们的大脑陷入螺旋式的胡思乱想。它让我们开始思考每一个可能发生的灾难。当我们从我们二十多岁的角度来考虑这一点时，对吧，有很多未知数。我们（取决于你二十多岁时处于什么阶段）仍然相当年轻。你知道的，我们中的一些人其实才刚刚成年两年左右，
if you're 20 at this point, maximum nine years. So you're still really a child in, in regards to your 20s. You don't really have any idea of what's coming for you. That's kind of both the beauty and the chaos of this decade. And so this constant analysis, this overthinking, it creates a sense of false control over our circumstances. Because we think that we can prevent negative outcomes by, you know, fortune telling them, by thinking this situation over. I think keeping ourselves stuck in what I would call problem solving mode makes us feel like there is a solution if we just think hard enough and long enough about our circumstances. It's this fairly common mental fallacy and the unconscious reasoning is essentially if I can
if you're 20 at this point, maximum nine years. So you're still really a child in, in regards to your 20s. You don't really have any idea of what's coming for you. That's kind of both the beauty and the chaos of this decade. And so this constant analysis, this overthinking, it creates a sense of false control over our circumstances. Because we think that we can prevent negative outcomes by, you know, fortune telling them, by thinking this situation over. I think keeping ourselves stuck in what I would call problem solving mode makes us feel like there is a solution if we just think hard enough and long enough about our circumstances. It's this fairly common mental fallacy and the unconscious reasoning is essentially if I can|||如果你此时 20 岁的话，最多也就九年。所以就你的二十多岁而言，你真的还是个孩子。你根本不知道未来会发生什么。这可以说是这个十年既美丽又混乱的地方。因此，这种不断的分析，这种过度思考，对我们的处境产生了一种虚假的控制感。因为我们认为我们可以通过（你知道的）预测未来、通过把这种情况反反复复地想清楚来阻止负面结果。我认为让自己陷入我所谓的“解决问题模式”会让我们觉得，只要我们对自己的处境进行足够刻苦、足够长时间的思考，就一定有解决办法。这是一种相当普遍的心理谬误，其无意识的推理本质上是：如果我能
imagine every possible outcome. If I can think about this a million and one ways over, no matter what the outcome is, I'll be prepared. And yet, we actually can't predict the outcome. We can't predict the future. And this heightened state of alertness and rumination means that we actually will probably make worse decisions or we won't make a decision at all. I think moreover overthinking also stems from a desire to avoid mistakes or failure. By excessively dwelling on past experiences or hypothetical futures, we attempt to anticipate and prevent our potential errors, and that leads to a perpetual cycle of overthinking. None of us like feeling like a failure, especially when we have high expectations for ourselves or for the situation. And we want to
imagine every possible outcome. If I can think about this a million and one ways over, no matter what the outcome is, I'll be prepared. And yet, we actually can't predict the outcome. We can't predict the future. And this heightened state of alertness and rumination means that we actually will probably make worse decisions or we won't make a decision at all. I think moreover overthinking also stems from a desire to avoid mistakes or failure. By excessively dwelling on past experiences or hypothetical futures, we attempt to anticipate and prevent our potential errors, and that leads to a perpetual cycle of overthinking. None of us like feeling like a failure, especially when we have high expectations for ourselves or for the situation. And we want to|||想象出每一个可能的结果。如果我能用一万种不同的方式把这件事想透，无论结果如何，我都能做好准备。然而，我们实际上无法预测结果。我们无法预测未来。这种高度的警觉和反刍状态意味着，我们实际上很可能会做出更糟糕的决定，或者根本不做决定。我认为此外，过度思考也源于一种避免犯错或失败的愿望。通过过度纠结于过去的经验或假设的未来，我们试图预测并防止我们潜在的错误，这导致了一个永无止境的过度思考循环。我们谁都不喜欢觉得自己像个失败者，尤其是当我们对自己或某种情况抱有很高的期望时。我们想要
avoid that uncomfortable feeling and protect our self-esteem. So our brain employs overthinking as a way to essentially predict what situations might present the opportunity to make a wrong decision and how we can prevent that failure. I think we may also develop this fear in relation to other people and their experiences and hearing from them. This is called informational learning in psychology. You know, for example, your friend is doing this like really hardcore. that you have to do. And they tell you how difficult it is and the fail rate for the final exam, et cetera, et cetera. And what you may find is that you deliberately then avoid that course or that situation or find yourself overthinking how you're going to approach it because you are so bound up
avoid that uncomfortable feeling and protect our self-esteem. So our brain employs overthinking as a way to essentially predict what situations might present the opportunity to make a wrong decision and how we can prevent that failure. I think we may also develop this fear in relation to other people and their experiences and hearing from them. This is called informational learning in psychology. You know, for example, your friend is doing this like really hardcore. that you have to do. And they tell you how difficult it is and the fail rate for the final exam, et cetera, et cetera. And what you may find is that you deliberately then avoid that course or that situation or find yourself overthinking how you're going to approach it because you are so bound up|||避免那种不舒服的感觉并保护我们的自尊。因此，我们的大脑采用过度思考作为一种方式，本质上是去预测哪些情况可能会提供做出错误决定的机会，以及我们如何才能防止这种失败。我想我们也会由于其他人、他们的经历以及听取他们的意见而产生这种恐惧。在心理学中，这被称为信息学习。你知道的，例如，你的朋友正在修一门非常硬核的课程，而你也必须修。他们告诉你这有多难，期末考试的挂科率是多少，等等等等。而你可能会发现，你随后会故意避开那门课程或那种情况，或者发现自己过度思考该如何应对它，因为你被……深深地束缚住了
in your fear of failure. Maybe this won't surprise you, but this is highly correlated to perfectionist tendencies. If you listen to my episode on perfectionism and academic anxiety, you'll know this already, but often if we aren't convinced we can do something perfectly, we will avoid doing it all together. In other words, we procrastinate because we are so consumed by not meeting our standards or the standards that have been imposed on us. Procrastination isn't about a lack of capability or ability. It occurs because we don't feel mentally prepared to perform or complete a task and get the outcome that we want. We become so overwhelmed by the idea that what we produce won't be perfect, that we habitually avoid doing it. If you've ever found yourself
in your fear of failure. Maybe this won't surprise you, but this is highly correlated to perfectionist tendencies. If you listen to my episode on perfectionism and academic anxiety, you'll know this already, but often if we aren't convinced we can do something perfectly, we will avoid doing it all together. In other words, we procrastinate because we are so consumed by not meeting our standards or the standards that have been imposed on us. Procrastination isn't about a lack of capability or ability. It occurs because we don't feel mentally prepared to perform or complete a task and get the outcome that we want. We become so overwhelmed by the idea that what we produce won't be perfect, that we habitually avoid doing it. If you've ever found yourself|||你对失败的恐惧中。也许这不会让你感到惊讶，但这与完美主义倾向高度相关。如果你听过我关于完美主义和学术焦虑的那期节目，你就会知道了，但通常如果我们不确信自己能把某件事做到完美，我们就会彻底避免去做它。换句话说，我们拖延是因为我们太过于执着于无法达到我们的标准或是强加给我们的标准。拖延并不是因为缺乏能力。它的发生是因为我们觉得自己在心理上还没有准备好去执行或完成一项任务并获得我们想要的结果。我们被“我们产出的东西不会是完美的”这一想法压得喘不过气来，以至于我们习惯性地避免去做它。如果你曾经发现自己
kind of staring at the blank page of an assignment, already anticipating what it would feel like to get a bad grade, and really paralyzed by how to start, perfectionism might actually be the root of your overthinking. As hard as it is to acknowledge, we are all going to fail. throughout our lives, a million times over in a million different ways. And also in ways that we could never anticipate, no matter how much your brain tries to trick you that you can avoid it by overthinking. I think maturity comes from recognizing that, although no amount of ruminating will protect you,
kind of staring at the blank page of an assignment, already anticipating what it would feel like to get a bad grade, and really paralyzed by how to start, perfectionism might actually be the root of your overthinking. As hard as it is to acknowledge, we are all going to fail. throughout our lives, a million times over in a million different ways. And also in ways that we could never anticipate, no matter how much your brain tries to trick you that you can avoid it by overthinking. I think maturity comes from recognizing that, although no amount of ruminating will protect you,|||盯着作业的空白页，已经在预想得一个坏分数会是什么感觉，并被如何开始给彻底难住了，那么完美主义实际上可能就是你过度思考的根源。尽管很难承认，但我们所有人都会失败。在我们的整个一生中，会在无数种不同的方式下失败上百万次。而且还会以我们永远无法预料的方式失败，无论你的大脑如何试图欺诈你，让你以为通过过度思考就能避免它。我认为成熟来自于认识到：尽管再怎么反刍也不会保护你，
whatever does happen, you get to decide how you'll respond. A mindset I try and adopt is that every failure is actually just a lesson in disguise. It's a scenic detour on which you get to learn so much more about yourself than if everything had kind of gone right. And also, I think making the wrong decision is always better than making no decision at all. Because remaining stagnant, not doing anything, is one of the worst things we can really do in our 20s. We have so many possibilities. There's this study, I always cite it, and I'm going to sign it again. But you are going to regret the choices you don't make more.
whatever does happen, you get to decide how you'll respond. A mindset I try and adopt is that every failure is actually just a lesson in disguise. It's a scenic detour on which you get to learn so much more about yourself than if everything had kind of gone right. And also, I think making the wrong decision is always better than making no decision at all. Because remaining stagnant, not doing anything, is one of the worst things we can really do in our 20s. We have so many possibilities. There's this study, I always cite it, and I'm going to sign it again. But you are going to regret the choices you don't make more.|||但无论发生什么，你都可以决定你将如何做出回应。我试图采用的一种心态是：每一次失败其实都只是伪装成失败的教训。这是一条风景优美的绕路，在这条路上，你对自己了解到的东西要比一切顺利时多得多。而且，我认为做出错误的决定总是比什么决定都不做要好。因为原地踏步、什么都不做，真的是我们在 20 多岁时能做出的最糟糕的事情之一。我们有那么多的可能性。有这样一项研究，我总是引用它，而我打算再次引用它。但你会对你没有做出的选择感到更多的后悔，
than the choices that you do. Over and over again, they find this. So it might not be the perfect decision. Maybe it won't guarantee complete happiness, but at least you've made it. The other origin of overthinking, I think, is really important to discuss is childhood environment and our early learning experiences. Most people who have developed a tendency to overthink and a subsequent difficulty with decision making have acquired this habit in childhood, particularly if they were raised in an unpredictable environment. As children, we are incredibly vulnerable and dependent on our caregivers for literally everything.
than the choices that you do. Over and over again, they find this. So it might not be the perfect decision. Maybe it won't guarantee complete happiness, but at least you've made it. The other origin of overthinking, I think, is really important to discuss is childhood environment and our early learning experiences. Most people who have developed a tendency to overthink and a subsequent difficulty with decision making have acquired this habit in childhood, particularly if they were raised in an unpredictable environment. As children, we are incredibly vulnerable and dependent on our caregivers for literally everything.|||而不是你做出的选择。他们一遍又一遍地发现了这一点。所以这可能不是最完美的决定。也许它不能保证带来完全的幸福，但至少你做出了决定。我认为另一个非常重要的、需要讨论的过度思考的根源是童年环境和我们早期的学习经历。大多数养成过度思考倾向以及随之而来的决策困难的人，都是在童年时期养成了这种习惯，特别是如果他们是在一个不可预测的环境中长大的话。作为小孩子，我们极其脆弱，在字面意义上的方方面面都依赖于我们的照顾者。
We also don't yet possess those coping mechanisms to deal with uncertainty in an appropriate manner. So for example, if you had parents who were perhaps unpredictable, maybe they dealt with addiction or they were constantly moving around or changing your routines, they weren't there for you, or in severe cases maybe they were abusive. As children, we use overthinking as a way to bring about a sense of control over our surroundings
We also don't yet possess those coping mechanisms to deal with uncertainty in an appropriate manner. So for example, if you had parents who were perhaps unpredictable, maybe they dealt with addiction or they were constantly moving around or changing your routines, they weren't there for you, or in severe cases maybe they were abusive. As children, we use overthinking as a way to bring about a sense of control over our surroundings|||我们还不具备以适当方式应对不确定性的那些应对机制。所以例如，如果你的父母可能有些喜怒无常，也许他们有瘾头问题，或者他们经常搬家或改变你的日常生活规律，他们不在你身边，或者在严重的情况下，他们可能虐待你。作为孩子，我们使用过度思考作为一种方式，来对我们周围的环境产生一种掌控感，
and to be prepared for what might be thrown at us. This has the result of perhaps momentarily lessening our anxiety, but it actually contributes to using or developing a maladaptive thinking style. The more we react to a situation by overthinking as a way to self-soothe in the presence of chaos and uncertainty, the more deeply ingrained this coping mechanism becomes. And as we grow up, it becomes more difficult to replace this thinking style because as children, we didn't really have the self-awareness to understand that it may be harmful. And so it's maintained into adulthood.
and to be prepared for what might be thrown at us. This has the result of perhaps momentarily lessening our anxiety, but it actually contributes to using or developing a maladaptive thinking style. The more we react to a situation by overthinking as a way to self-soothe in the presence of chaos and uncertainty, the more deeply ingrained this coping mechanism becomes. And as we grow up, it becomes more difficult to replace this thinking style because as children, we didn't really have the self-awareness to understand that it may be harmful. And so it's maintained into adulthood.|||并为可能向我们袭来的事情做好准备。这带来的结果可能是暂时减轻了我们的焦虑，但它实际上助长了使用或发展出一种适应不良的思维方式。我们在面对混乱和不确定性时，越是习惯性地通过过度思考来作为自我安慰的方式来对某种情况做出反应，这种应对机制就越根深蒂固。随着我们长大，这种思维方式就越难被取代，因为作为孩子，我们并没有真正的自我意识去理解它可能是具有危害性的。因此，这种习惯一直保持到了成年。
I think with all disordered thinking or maladaptive habits such as this one, I think it is really valuable to assess what the childhood origins may have been. Additionally, if as children we maybe felt like we didn't have much agency over our life, this may also make it difficult to make decisions and cause us to be paralyzed by overthinking because we don't feel confident enough in our own abilities and discernment. I would love to see a study on that, actually. I think it would be so fascinating, such a fascinating research topic, you know, the intersections between childhood, blame and ownership over responsibility and adulthood.
I think with all disordered thinking or maladaptive habits such as this one, I think it is really valuable to assess what the childhood origins may have been. Additionally, if as children we maybe felt like we didn't have much agency over our life, this may also make it difficult to make decisions and cause us to be paralyzed by overthinking because we don't feel confident enough in our own abilities and discernment. I would love to see a study on that, actually. It would be so fascinating, such a fascinating research topic, you know, the intersections between childhood, blame and ownership over responsibility and adulthood.|||我认为，对于所有紊乱的思维或诸如此类的适应不良的习惯，评估其童年根源是非常有价值的。此外，如果在童年中我们可能觉得我们对自己的生活没有什么自主权，这也可能会使我们难以做出决定，并导致我们因过度思考而瘫痪，因为我们对自己的能力和辨别力不够自信。其实我很想看到关于这方面的一项研究。那将是非常迷人、非常引人入胜的研究课题，你知道的，童年、对责任的指责与拥有权以及成年之间的交叉点。
There you go. A research title, if anyone wants to do their thesis on that, it's all yours. I think another psychological factor contributing to overthinking is a heightened state of self-awareness and self-consciousness, which we spoke about before. We possess an inherent tendency to evaluate and judge ourselves, but we also have this tendency to seek the validation of others. That makes us inherently self-critical, and this self-critical mindset often fuels overthinking because we excessively scrutinize our actions and our decisions because we fear potential criticism or rejection. And social comparison plays a role in overthinking. Comparing ourselves to others, especially, of course, in the era of social media, can create
There you go. A research title, if anyone wants to do their thesis on that, it's all yours. I think another psychological factor contributing to overthinking is a heightened state of self-awareness and self-consciousness, which we spoke about before. We possess an inherentternal tendency to evaluate and judge ourselves, but we also have this tendency to seek the validation of others. That makes us inherently self-critical, and this self-critical mindset often fuels overthinking because we excessively scrutinize our actions and our decisions because we fear potential criticism or rejection. And social comparison plays a role in overthinking. Comparing ourselves to others, especially, of course, in the era of social media, can create|||给你。一个研究题目，如果有人想以此做论文，那就拿去吧。我认为导致过度思考的另一个心理因素是高度的自我意识和自我关注，我们之前讨论过这一点。我们拥有评估和评判自己的内在倾向，但我们也有寻求他人认可的倾向。这使我们天生就具有自我批判性，而这种自我批判的心态往往会助长过度思考，因为我们过度审视自己的行为和决定，因为我们害怕潜在的批评或拒绝。社交比较在过度思考中也扮演着一定角色。将自己与他人进行比较，尤其是当然在社交媒体时代，会产生
unrealistic expectations and then I think therefore a constant need to measure up, a constant kind of standard that we feel we need to meet and that we feel we need to compare ourselves to resulting in this overthinking in this spiral about our worth and our achievements. Those are some of the high-level psychological explanations, but we cannot, we cannot talk about overthinking without examining the relationship to diagnosable mental health conditions like generalised anxiety and ADHD. So we are going to discuss that and so much more after this. short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator
unrealistic expectations and then I think therefore a constant need to measure up, a constant kind of standard that we feel we need to meet and that we feel we need to compare ourselves to resulting in this overthinking in this spiral about our worth and our achievements. Those are some of the high-level psychological explanations, but we cannot, we cannot talk about overthinking without examining the relationship to diagnosable mental health conditions like generalised anxiety and ADHD. So we are going to discuss that and so much more after this. short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator|||不切实际的期望，然后我认为因此就会产生一种不断需要达到标准的恒定需求，一种我们觉得我们需要满足的、我们觉得我们需要与之进行比较的恒定标准，从而导致了这场关于我们的价值和成就的过度思考的漩涡。这些是一些高水平的心理学解释，但是我们不能（绝对不能）在不探讨过度思考与广泛性焦虑和多动症（ADHD）等可诊断的心理健康状况之间的关系的情况下谈论过度思考。因此，在短暂休息之后，我们将讨论这个以及更多内容。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。
available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.|||我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在这个奇怪的现代世界中如何建立心理韧性、保持健康以及培养适应力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等对话，带大家看透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾经坚信种子油天生具有炎症性。我们弄错了。世界上让我们感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你将在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。
Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English.
去听 2%。那是 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方上的 T-W-O-Percent。你还记得 Diana Ross 在 VMA 上突然拍了 Little Kim 的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟 Little Kim 有毛线关系？好吧，你可以在 Look Back at it 播客中找到答案。我是 Sam J。还有我 Alex English。
Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of Congress. crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line.
每一集，我们都会挑选一个这里，剖析发生了什么，并试着理解我们是怎么挺过来的。包括最近一期邀请了马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）的节目，畅谈 80 年代的快克（crack）。说清楚点，84年对我很重要，不只是因为国会。快克。我随时都可以聊聊快克，但只是想让你们知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们第二期讨论快克了。所以我开始看出一条贯穿的线索了。
We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your Podcasts.
我们现在还把艾滋病摆上了台面。谢谢你把话说完。我觉得没有比这更重要的一年了，对于黑人来说。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Look Back at it。
Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade
欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是主持人、也是你最喜欢的治疗师 Kear Games。为了纪念心理健康意识月，我带来了十多年的
of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing,
我在心理健康领域的亲身经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是。特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时当我们追求某样东西时，
we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross,
我们太沉迷于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们还在追逐。而且我们不知道什么时候才算够。因为人们在看记分牌。生活成了关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），
because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on Earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing,
因为你觉得在这个地球上做一个好人很重要？你做个好人是因为你害怕吗?因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。完全正确。这也是两个不同层次的信任。我希望你真正地去做一个好人。和我 Kear Games 一起，在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，进行关于疗愈、
growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app, Search learn the hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct?
成长、父职、压力和目标的真实对话。打开你免费的 iHeartRadio App，搜索 Learn the Hard Way 并立即收听。2023年，前“钻石王老五”明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家庭法庭听证会暴露了他故事中明显的矛盾之处。这开始了长达数年的法庭之战来证明真相。你对这个特定的测试动了两次手脚，对吗？
I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown.
我篡改了一次测试。这需要一大群互联网侦探来破案。我希望人们能看到他们的税款被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会发现一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安（Greg Alespian）和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我惊呆了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Maricopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until Justice. is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听
podcasts. The act of overthinking can be linked to a number of psychological problems, such as anxiety and depression, although it's kind of hard to know what happens first in most cases. This researcher put it really perfectly when they said it's a very quintessential chicken or egg kind of conundrum. However, one of the primary symptoms of a generalized anxiety disorder is not only persistent anxiety, but also overthinking and someone who plans for all possible worst case scenarios. When we get down to the biological reasons why this occurs, we can see, I think, more clearly,
播客《Love Trapped》。过度思考的行为与许多心理问题有关，例如焦虑和抑郁，尽管在大多数情况下很难知道哪个先发生。这位研究人员说得非常完美，当他们说这是一种非常典型的先有鸡还是先有蛋的难题时。然而，广泛性焦虑障碍的主要症状之一不仅是持续的焦虑，还有过度思考，以及为所有可能的最坏情况做计划的人。当我们追溯到导致这一现象的生物学原因时，我们可以更清楚地看到，
where overthinking actually comes from. And it's really not your fault. A range of neurotransmitters are responsible for the typical symptoms of anxiety. with that overthinking. For example, serotonin, glutamate, GABA, and the hormone norapinephrine, it's otherwise known as adrenaline, they all play a role in modulating our anxiety response. So one study found that when levels of GABA in our brain are too low, it can trigger excessive worrying and excessive overthinking because GABA is what helps control the signals between the nerve cells in our brains. So when
过度思考实际上是从哪里来的。这真的不是你的错。一系列神经递质导致了焦虑的典型症状。伴随着那种过度思考。例如，5-羟色胺（serotonin）、谷氨酸（glutamate）、GABA（γ-氨基丁酸），以及去甲肾上腺素（norepinephrine）这种激素——也就是通常所说的肾上腺素，它们都在调节我们的焦虑反应中发挥作用。因此一项研究发现，当我们大脑中的 GABA 水平太低时，它会引发过度的担忧和过度思考，因为 GABA 有助于控制我们大脑中神经细胞之间的信号。所以当
these signals are not mediated, when they're not moderated by this neurotransmitter, our brain goes into overdrive. There's nothing kind of stopping those neural pathways from constantly firing. And that's when we really start to feel like our brain is on a bit of a hamster wheel, that we are not in control of our thoughts. It's important to note here that overthinking is just one symptom. And it's not a diagnosable disorder. You cannot be diagnosed with overthinking. It's just a cognitive process that is associated with a broader condition, that being anxiety that is characterized by this fear, by this excessive worry and hypervigilance. But I think it's really worth examining whether the root of this thought pattern could be
这些信号没有被介导，没有被这种神经递质调节时，我们的大脑就会进入超负荷运转。没有什么能阻止这些神经通路不断放电。也就是在这个时候，我们真正开始觉得自己的大脑就像在一个仓鼠轮上，我们无法控制自己的思想。这里需要注意的是，过度思考只是一种症状。它不是一种可诊断的障碍。你不会被诊断出患有过度思考。它只是一种与更广泛的状况相关的认知过程，也就是以这种恐惧、这种过度担忧和过度警惕为特征的焦虑。但我认为非常值得探讨的是，这种思维模式的根源是否可以通过
mitigated by managing your overall anxiety levels. There is also this concept of depressive rumination, which is a form of overthinking where we feel almost comforted by dwelling on the past and what we regret. By going over our mistakes or our regrets again and again, it's like kind of how waves turn glass into sand or smooth out hard surfaces. Each time we examine a memory, it becomes more blunt. And when we ruminate on it, we lessen the emotional pain attached to it, or so we think. That might just be a myth, because it may actually be the more we think about something it actually aggravates our anxiety response. It makes it harder to let that
控制你的整体焦虑水平来减轻。还有一个概念叫作抑郁性反刍（depressive rumination），这是一种过度思考的形式，在这种形式中，我们沉浸在过去和遗憾中，几乎会感到一丝安慰。一遍又一遍地反思我们的错误或遗憾，有点像海浪把玻璃变成沙子，或者把坚硬的表面磨平。每次我们审视一段记忆，它就会变得更钝一些。当我们反刍它时，我们减轻了附着在它上面的情感痛苦，或者我们是这么认为的。这可能只是个神话，因为事实上，我们对某事的思考越多，实际上越会加剧我们的焦虑反应。这让那段
memory pass and it elevates our distress. I think it's a super fine line to walk. You really do have to process what you go through, but when you find that you cannot stop returning to something that was cringe or embarrassing or something that was maybe even traumatic, there are some really major negative consequences to that. That's why this kind of cognitive process is associated with a major depressive disorder, in some instances, not all, of course. The other mental mental health condition I want to discuss is ADHD. I will say I'm not an expert on this. This was just a really fascinating article that I read and I think it's valuable to put forward. But whilst we, I think most typically associate ADHD with hyperactivity and impulsivity, it also manifests an
记忆更难消逝，并增加了我们的痛苦。我认为这是一条非常微妙的界限。你确实必须处理你所经历的事情，但当你发现自己无法停止回想那些尴尬的、令人窘迫的事情，甚至是可能是创伤性的事情时，这会带来一些非常重大的负面后果。这就是为什么这种认知过程在某些情况下（当然不是全部）与重度抑郁症有关。我想讨论的另一种心理健康状况是 ADHD（注意缺陷多动障碍）。我得说我不是这方面的专家。这只是一篇我读到的非常fascinating的文章，我认为把它提出来很有价值。但是，虽然我们大多数人最典型地将 ADHD 与多动和冲动联系在一起，它也表现为
excessive ruminating and an inability to break out of a specific thought pattern. Individuals with ADHD, they often report obsessive thoughts and difficulty regulating or bringing their thoughts under control. Once again, it can be a primary symptom that may lead someone to seek an ADHD diagnosis. You know, it might be that first kind of red flag. If you can't stop overthinking and you can't stop obsessively thinking about something, maybe it's a sign that you do need to seek professional help if that is the case. not all overthinking is generally indicative of a larger problem. It is just a typical symptom for some people.
过度的反刍以及无法打破特定的思维模式。患有 ADHD 的人经常报告有强迫性想法，并且难以调节或控制自己的思想。再一次，这可能是一个主要症状，可能会导致某人寻求 ADHD 诊断。你知道，这可能是第一个红旗信号。如果你停不下过度思考，也停不下对某事的强迫性思考，也许这是一个迹象，表明如果情况确实如此，你确实需要寻求专业帮助。并非所有的过度思考通常都预示着更大的问题。对某些人来说，这只是一种典型的症状。
So take it with a grain of salt and maybe go and see someone if you're finding that it's really interrupting your ability to function. Now that we've kind of discussed the theories behind overthinking and the subsequent indecisiveness that tends to come from it, I think we really need to explore the ways in which we can bring this behaviour or this tendency under control. role. Part of that is understanding the types of decision makers that we are and how we can reprogram our brain to kind of ignore the tiny, itty-bitty details and ignore all the possible pathways and just focus on the bigger picture. Back in the early 2000s, the psychologists, they came
所以请辩证地看待它，如果你发现它确实干扰了你正常生活的能力，也许可以去看看医生。既然我们已经讨论了过度思考背后的理论以及随之而来的优柔寡断，我认为我们真的需要探索如何将这种行为或倾向控制在。角色的一部分是了解我们是什么类型的决策者，以及我们如何重新编程我们的大脑，去忽略那些微小的、细枝末节的细节，忽略所有可能的路径，只关注更大的宏观图景。早在 2000 年代初期，心理学家们就提出了
up with this theory that there are two types of decision makers in the world. There are satisfiers and there are maximizers. Satisfiers, they aim for a good enough solution. They have a very clear set of criteria that they are not trying to maximize, but just satisfy. And when their criteria is met, when they get what they're after, they're happy with that decision. They're really happy with it. They are what we would call highly utilitarian and practical. The example that people give is looking for a new car.
提出了这样一个理论：世界上有两种类型的决策者。有一种是满足者（satisfizers），另一种是最大化者（maximizers）。满足者，他们的目标是寻找一个“足够好”的解决方案。他们有一套非常明确的标准，他们不是试图将其最大化，而只是满足它。当他们的标准得到满足，当他们得到了他们所追求的，他们对这个决定感到高兴。他们真的很高兴。他们就是我们所说的极具功利性和实用性的人。人们给出的例子是寻找一辆新车。
That's a good one, actually. So if your main criteria is like, I want it to drive and I want it to be under $5,000, you you'll find a car that drives under $5,000, you'll purchase it. You're not looking for a car that can drive really, really well and is under $3,000. You're not constantly looking for the better option. You're just looking for something that meets or satisfies those criteria. In contrast, maximizers are not satisfied unless they have the best possible outcome, the perfect solution.
这其实是一个很好的例子。所以如果你的主要标准是，我想要它能开，而且价格在 5000 美元以下，你就会找到一辆能开且低于 5000 美元的车，然后你就会买下它。你不会一直在找一辆能开得非常好而且低于 3000 美元的车。你不会一直寻找更好的选择。你只是在寻找符合或满足这些标准的东西。相比之下，最大化者如果不拥有最好的可能结果、完美的解决方案，是不会感到满足的。
but often in aiming for that kind of perfect outcome, they have very ambiguous criteria. It's really based on the right feeling. And interestingly, in this study conducted in 2007, they found that these types of decision makers are actually less happy compared to satisfiers because maximizers are constantly preoccupied with the what if. What if I find something better? What if something better comes along in the future? and I've already accepted this other decision.
但在追求那种完美结果的过程中，他们的标准往往非常模糊。它实际上是基于“正确的感觉”。有趣的是，在 2007 年进行的一项研究中，他们发现这类决策者实际上比满足者更不快乐，因为最大化者总是全神贯注于“如果……会怎样”。如果我找到更好的东西怎么办？如果未来出现更好的东西怎么办？而我已经接受了另外这个决定。
They also reported more avoidance of decision making in general, that chronic indecisiveness that we're talking about, and they're more likely to report impulsive, spontaneous decision making, which sounds counterintuitive, but I think the reasoning behind that is because they are so consumed with overthinking what the best possible outcome could be, that they procrastinate. And when they actually do have to make the decision,
他们还报告说，总体上更多地回避做决定，也就是我们正在谈论的那种长期的优柔寡断，并且他们更有可能报告冲动、自发的决策，这听起来有些反直觉，但我认为背后的原因是，他们太专注于过度思考什么是最好的可能结果，以至于他们拖延了。而当他们真正不得不做出决定时，
it's often closer to the deadline, or they do so impulsively because they're so exhausted from this rumination, from considering all the possible outcomes, that they no longer have the brain space to actually make a proper decision. So they do so spontaneously. In order to address our underlying tendency to overthink and therefore that chronic indecisiveness, what we need to do is shift from being a maximizer to a satisfier.
这通常更接近截止日期，或者他们这样做很冲动，因为他们已经被这种反刍折腾得筋疲力尽，考虑了所有可能的结果，以至于他们不再有脑力去真正做出一个正确的决定。所以他们就自发地去做了。为了解决我们潜在的过度思考倾向以及由此带来的长期优柔寡断，我们需要做的是从最大化者转变为满足者。
And that involves a few things. When you are faced with a decision, narrow down the solution using chunking. This is a psychological idea whereby a big group of information is broken down into smaller parts and grouped by common elements or easier problems. So this really allows you to tackle a big decision by turning it into a series of smaller choices. And it also allows our brain to channel that energy we use to overthink into a meaningful problem solving strategy and it makes the problem less profound and it makes it seem less life-changing when we kind of take off those smaller chunks. So for example, someone actually messaged me with
这涉及几件事。当你面临一个决定时，用“分块（chunking）”法缩小解决方案。这是一个心理学概念，通过它，一大组信息被分解成更小的部分，并按共同元素或更简单的问题进行分组。这确实允许你通过将一个重大决定变成一系列更小的选择来解决它。这也让我们的大脑能够将用于过度思考的能量引导到有意义的问题解决策略中，它使问题显得没那么深奥，当我们把那些较小的块剥离时，它看起来就没那么改变人生。例如，有人实际上给我发信息说
this conundrum they were having the other day of choosing between two job options and one of them paid more, but the other one was more aligned with what they enjoyed and what they saw themselves doing in the future. Using that satisfy a principle, and that method of chunking, we need to break down our two options and break down that information using a series of discerning questions. So in this example, you know, can I live off the salary of the second job? Would I be able to pay my bills? That's like a minimum criteria for living. Then there's that second question of what actually matters more to me right now? This is personal preference and values. Financial security or workplace satisfaction. And then let's look to the future.
他们最近遇到了一个困境，要在两个工作选项之间做出选择，其中一个薪水更高，但另一个更符合他们的兴趣以及他们对未来自己的设想。运用那个满足者的原则，以及那个分块的方法，我们需要分解我们的两个选项，并使用一系列敏锐的问题来分解这些信息。所以在这个例子中，你知道，我能靠第二份工作的薪水生活吗？我能付得起账单吗？这就像是生活的最低标准。然后是第二个问题，现在对真正我更重要的是什么？这是个人偏好和价值观。财务安全还是工作场所满意度。然后让我们展望未来，
what are the opportunities for promotion or further development? Which job is going to offer me more in the next five years or ten years around career development? From those questions, we can kind of create a bit of a rudimentary pros and cons list. So instead of feeling paralyzed by this big choice, we can approach it as a satisfier would. What are the minimum conditions for my happiness here? And which of these choices meets those minimum conditions? I think it's also to remember that everything in life is temporary and fixable. The decision you make right now, it's not going to lock you in for the rest of your life.
晋升或进一步发展的机会是什么？哪份工作在未来五年或十年内能在职业发展方面为我提供更多？从这些问题中，我们可以建立一个初步的利弊清单。因此，我们不会被这个重大的选择搞得瘫痪，而是可以像一个满足者那样去对待它。我在这里快乐的最低条件是什么？这些选择中哪一个满足了这些最低条件？我认为还要记住，生活中的一切都是暂时的，是可以修复的。你现在做出的决定，不会把你锁死在余生中。
You can always admit that maybe you made a mistake or you made the wrong choice and go back and fix that. Or also maybe even find yourself satisfied even though that choice may not have been perfect. Life is kind of what you make of it. So many times you think that you will be. more satisfied doing something else, but the grass is, as they say, always greener on the other side. So overthinking it isn't actually going to make you happier or give you the outcome that you want. Another massive strategy, this is my favorite strategy. I personally use this a lot when I'm overthinking is to find some way to make your thoughts tangible and organized. When we overthink,
你随时都可以承认自己可能犯了错误或做出了错误的选择，然后回去纠正它。或者甚至可能发现自己很满足，即使这个选择可能并不完美。生活就是你塑造它的样子。很多时候你以为你会。通过做其他事情变得更满足，但正如他们所说，草永远是另一边的更绿。所以过度思考并不能真正让你更快乐，也不能给你带来你想要的结果。另一个巨大的策略，这是我最喜欢的策略。我个人在过度思考时经常使用这个方法，那就是找到某种方法让你的想法变得有形且有条理。当我们过度思考时，
everything in our brain feels like a mess it feels like this big group of like unruly vines that have just tangled up in our brain but there's this saying that a problem on a page is a problem halved hold that anxiety or worry or that thought in your mind grab a pen and paper and spend 20 30 minutes however long writing down every single aspect of the problem that is concerning you every possible ramification, every possible element. Get those thoughts out into the open and you'll suddenly find they are a lot more manageable because you're actually able to do something productive with them. You feel like you've done something useful.
我们大脑中的一切都感觉像是一团糟，感觉就像一大群不守规矩的藤蔓纠缠在我们的大脑里，但有这样一句名言：纸上的问题就是解决了一半的问题。把那种焦虑、担忧或那种想法抓在脑海里，拿一支笔和一张纸，花 20、30 分钟，不管花多久，写下困扰你的问题的每一个方面，每一个可能的后果，每一个可能的元素。把这些想法表达出来，你突然会发现它们更容易控制了，因为你实际上可以用它们做一些富有成效的事情。你觉得你做了一些有用的事情。
I also find that it can really minimize some of our own internal delusions. Sometimes things that seem highly probable in our brain can sound so silly when we speak out loud, or when we put them in writing, because we let our minds process that information in a different format. It's the same reason why talking about a problem with a friend often helps us ease our anxiety and tendency to overthink, because when we speak it out loud, we kind of see how irrational we might be, you know, how irrational we might be. And I think that kind of tactic of making what is normally internal, external, and making it tangible, has personally really, really helped me out. Distraction also helps. I know that sounds like a cop-out,
我也发现它确实可以最大程度地减少我们自己的一些内心妄想。有时在我们的脑海中看起来极有可能发生的事情，当我们大声说出来时，或者当我们把它写下来时，听起来会很愚蠢，因为我们让大脑以不同的格式处理这些信息。这也是为什么和朋友谈论一个问题通常有助于我们缓解焦虑和过度思考的倾向，因为当我们大声说出来时，我们有点能看到自己可能是多么不理性，你知道，可能是多么不理性。我认为这种把通常是内在的东西外在化、使其有形化的策略，对我个人真的非常有帮助。分散注意力也有帮助。我知道这听起来像是在逃避，
but sometimes we just need some peace and quiet, and we want to give our brains a rest. Telling yourself to stop thinking about it will never work, but making it harder for your brain to think about it does. Our minds, at the end of the day, have limited space. So when we fill up that space with the challenging activity, like doing a puzzle or listening to a podcast and going for a run or reading a book and listening to music, something that activates multiple parts of our brain, we kind of jam all the channels, meaning that our anxiety is and our overthinking and our indecisiveness and those problems that we have or those thought patterns, they can't get through and it makes it really difficult for our brain to ruminate on them. Obviously though,
但有时我们只是需要一些和平与安静，我们想让大脑休息一下。告诉自己不要去想它永远不管用，但让你的大脑更难去想它确实管用。归根结底，我们的大脑空间有限。所以当我们用具有挑战性的活动填满这个空间时，比如做拼图、听播客、去跑步、看书或听音乐，做一些能激活我们大脑多个部分的事情，我们就有点堵塞了所有的通道，这意味着我们的焦虑和我们的过度思考、我们的优柔寡断以及我们遇到的那些问题或那些思维模式无法穿透进来，这使得我们的大脑很难对它们进行反刍。显然，
I think it would be unethical if I didn't say that this is a short-term solution. And sometimes we do need to go a lot deeper to kind of identify those bad mental habits and what we would call automatic negative thoughts in psychology. So an automatic negative thought, it refers to a pattern of negative thinking that interrupts our ability to make decisions. This ranges from things like overthinking, but also fortune telling, which is an element of overthinking and overgeneralizations, should statements, I should do this, I should have. have done that and also jumping to conclusions, feeling like you know what's going to happen, catastrophizing in a situation. We can train ourselves to identify when these types of thoughts
如果我不说这是一个短期解决方案，那我就太不道德了。有时我们确实需要更深入地去识别那些糟糕的心理习惯，以及我们在心理学中所说的自动消极想法。因此，自动消极想法指的是一种消极思维模式，它会打断我们做出决定的能力。这包括过度思考，但也包括灾难预言（fortune telling）——这是过度思考的一个要素，还有过度概括、应该语句（我应该这样做，我本应该。这样做），以及跳跃性结论（jumping to conclusions），觉得自己知道会发生什么，在情境中灾难化。我们可以训练自己识别这些类型的想法。
are present and deliberately refocus our thinking. Catch the thought, write it down, examine the evidence for it. Why do you think that you're going to fail? Why do you think those people don't like you? Why do you think you're making the wrong decision? Why do you think that person is mad at you? Is there evidence for this thought or is it just an automatic negative thought that you've internalized? Part of that is also going to see a therapist or a psychologist. Someone asked me the other day like is therapy actually worth it? I think that in these situations, in all situations, it actually really is because this person is completely imparting. Their only focus in those sessions is to tell you the truth and help you through your problems.
是存在的，并刻意重新聚焦我们的思维。抓住这个想法，把它写下来，检验支持它的证据。你为什么认为自己会失败？你为什么觉得那些人不喜欢你？你为什么觉得你做错了决定？你为什么觉得那个人生你的气？有证据支持这个想法吗，还是这只是你内化了的一个自动消极想法？其中一部分也是去看治疗师或心理学家。有人前几天问我， therapy 真的值得吗？我认为在这些情况下，在所有情况下，它其实真的很值得，因为这个人完全是不带偏见的。他们在那些会议中的唯一焦点就是告诉你真相，并帮助你解决问题。
So what they're going to do is really call you out for your negative thought patterns, for your automatic negative thoughts. They're going to hold you accountable when you're overthinking and kind of act of that, you know, as that voice of reason, that person who interrupts those thought patterns as they're occurring and asks you to correct them. you know, is this actually helpful? Is thinking about this really going to give you a solution? The chances are probably not.
所以他们要做的是真正指出你的消极思维模式，指出你的自动消极想法。当你过度思考时，他们会让你承担责任，并扮演那种理性的声音，那种在这些思维模式发生时打断它们并要求你纠正它们的人。你知道，这真的有帮助吗？思考这个真的能给你一个解决方案吗？可能性大概是没有。
Like we said, overthinking tricks our brain into thinking that if we mull something over a million times over, if we ruminate on it enough, somehow some new solutions, some new outcome will be discovered. And I don't really think that's ever the case. You don't really have to do it alone. I think that's the final message here. You know, it can be really paralyzing and really difficult. And I think it's worth considering what level of professional help is needed. You know, fear of failure, perfectionism, anxiety, whatever it is, your 20s should be a time for freedom and getting to enjoy all of those precious moments
正如我们所说，过度思考欺诈了我们的大脑，让我们以为如果我们把某件事琢磨上一百万遍，如果我们对它进行足够的反刍，不知何故就会发现一些新的解决方案，一些新的结果。我觉得这真的永远不会发生。你真的不必独自承受。我想这是最后的讯息。你知道，这可能会让人非常瘫痪且非常困难。我认为值得考虑需要什么水平的专业帮助。你知道，对失败的恐惧、完美主义、焦虑，无论是什么，你的 20 岁应该是一个享受自由的时期，去享受所有那些珍贵的时刻。
and all those little joys without constantly worrying about what comes next or who thinks what about you. So I would say from one chronic thinker to another, I really hope you find that piece. And I hope that this episode has been helpful. I guess my final reminder for the day is where you place your attention is where you place your energy. And although sometimes it can feel like our thoughts are in control, that is not the case. It is your brain. It is your mind. You have the ability to kind of sort through the rubble, sort through the mess.
还有所有那些小小的喜悦，而不用不断地担心接下来会发生什么，或者谁对你有什么看法。所以我想说，从一个长期过度思考的人到另一个，我真的希望你能找到内心的平静。我希望这一集对你有所帮助。我想我今天的最后提醒是，你把注意力放在哪里，你的能量就放在哪里。虽然有时我们会觉得自己的想法在控制我们，但事实并非如此。这是你的大脑。这是你的心灵。你有能力从废墟中筛选，从混乱中筛选。
and select what you want, select what you want from all of that, select what you want from the chaos. Also, you know, as much as it is a really common tendency, I think it's also really valuable to just quickly return to that point. A lot of this is to do with things that are outside of our control, this need for a sense of certainty, even some of those neurotransmitters like Gabba. Those are really kind of the culprit in this situation. so it's not some personal flaw it is sometimes just the way that our brains are wired and you don't need to fix yourself in order to cope with that thought pattern i think that's a really a really good place actually i want to i kind of want to end things because yeah i just think sometimes in my own
并挑选你想要的，从所有这些中挑选你想要的，从混乱中挑选你想要的。此外，你知道，尽管它是一种非常普遍的倾向，但我认为快速回到那一点也非常有价值。很多这都与我们无法控制的事情有关，这种对确定感的需求，甚至像 GABA 这样的神经递质。在这种情况下的确是真正的罪魁祸首，所以这不是什么个人的缺陷，有时这只是我们大脑的接线方式，你不需要为了应对这种思维模式而修复自己，我认为这其实是一个非常非常好的地方，我想要，我其实有点想结束事情，因为是的，我只是觉得有时候在我的。
personal life i like find myself overthinking and i'm like i just wish i could stop thinking about this i don't want to think about this i don't want to keep annoying my friends with this this like minor concern that they don't really care about. But knowing that it is, that it is, you know, somewhat of a natural, even evolutionary process has really helped me accept it, which means that I've been able to address it. So I really do hope that you enjoyed this episode. As always, if there is someone in your life who needs to hear this, you should send them a link. Maybe they will find it helpful. Maybe they won't. I don't really know. But it's always nice to show that you're thinking of them and that you know what they're going through. So please feel free
个人生活中，我发现自己在过度思考，我想我只希望我能停止思考这个，我不想去想这个，我不想再用这个他们并不真正在乎的小担忧来烦我的朋友了。但知道它是，它在某种程度上是一个自然的、甚至是进化的过程，这真的帮助我接受了它，这意味着我能够去解决它。所以我真的希望你喜欢这一集。像往常一样，如果你生命中有人需要听到这个，你应该把链接发给他们。也许他们会觉得有帮助。也许不会。我真的不知道。但展示你正在想着他们以及你了解他们正在经历的事情总是很好的。所以请随时
to share this episode along. If you also feel called to do so, no pressure, but please feel free to leave a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you are listening right now. It really helps this show. It helps it to reach new people. It helps me. So I really do value the support. And if you have an episode suggestion, please feel free to join me over. at that psychology podcast. I take any and all ideas. I add them to my list. And every now and again,
分享这一集。如果你也觉得有此冲动，没有压力，但请随时在 Apple Podcasts、Spotify 或你现在正在收听的任何地方留下五星好评。这真的对这个节目很有帮助。它帮助它接触到新的人。它帮助了我。所以我真的很感激这份支持。如果你有剧集建议，请随时加入我。在那个心理播客。我接受任何和所有的想法。我把它们加到我的名单上。时不时地，
I really like to pull something from what someone has suggested and dedicate a whole episode to it. So there's something that you're going through that you want a psychological explanation for. Please feel free to send it over. As always, we would be back next week with another episode.
我真的很喜欢从别人建议的内容中提取一些东西，并为之投入整整一集。所以有什么是你正在经历的，你想要一个心理学解释的？请随时发过来。像往常一样，我们下周会带着另一集回归。
See you then. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to learn the hard way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor?
回头见。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人 Kear Games 主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间关乎黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都绝对不安全的坦诚对话，但你是和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士一起进行的。有多少男人带着盔甲？
It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%.
它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做，请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯顿（Michael Easter）。我在我的播客《2%》中。
I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO.% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，心理坚韧、健身和建立韧性的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你会以一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人的身份从另一端走出来。收听 2%。那是 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方上的 TWO%。当一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast, For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
他会得到他应得的。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。听女朋友的话。相信我，宝贝。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在 Look Back at it 播客中，对 1979 年来说，那对我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year.
我是 Sam J。还有我 Alex English。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析发生了什么，并试着理解我们是怎么挺过来的。与我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员和最喜欢的作家一起。就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）谈论80年代一样。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。
I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我觉得没有比这更重要的一年了，对于黑人来说。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Look Back at it。这是一个 iHeart 播客。保证真人本期节目目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可留下评论。